it was like his child's chicken so I was
like I can't buy [__] killed the
chicken I would have got home the kid
was like yeah that's fine
we want to say thank you to our sponsor
fitba you are not the same person as you
were at the start of the year so it's
natural for your fitness journey to have
ups and downs wherever you are in your
fitness journey get the most out of
every workout with fitbod get 20 off
your subscription at
fitbod.me slash DPT that's
fitbod.me DPT
nice
thank you to our sponsor electric e-bike
hey if you want to open up your summer
and have a great time make sure to get
yourself electric e-bike there are easy
way to get outside and explore your
world with electric e-bike that's right
visit electricebikes.com to learn more
and explore the Epic models electric has
to offer that's electric e-bikes.com
l-e-c-t-r-i-c-e-bikes.com great hey
tatties welcome to another episode of
dumb people Town population
diamonds Tim Simons welcome to the show
again welcome back I'm so happy to be
here good to see you yeah you were one
of our all-time favorite guests and I'm
so happy oh my god really yeah yeah sure
you have a new podcast with uh Matt
Walsh well it's a return yes yeah yeah
we're now at all things comedy yes so
you're here yeah it's a great podcast
because it is two of our favorite people
two of the funniest people we know
recounting one of the funniest shows
with people who are also on that show
yeah so get into that you guys know we
don't talk about this at the top of the
show
what are we even doing I'm not looking
for compliments and maybe it's just so
that I know so that I can repeat it if
I'm ever well maybe today just like what
do you think it was that super present
had a lot of fun asked a lot of
questions and you were like there with
us all the way through ready to play
ready okay all right let's see if I can
keep that up no it's what you do all the
time it's what you do on every show and
everything that you were a part of so
we're gonna jump into it and last time
Dan had all three stories this time it
wrote each other you're still just
sitting and and partake okay we each
bring a dish to the party next Story
number one yeah let's do it he was sent
in by Liz Haggerty Atlas Haggerty love
her do you guys know this person
she's one of the editors of the dumb
Gazette yeah she's kind of one of our
stringers so basically what happens is
just for people who want to know maybe
you're listening for the first time
maybe you're a Tim Simons fan who came
to this podcast and said how do I send
in a story well it's quite easy you uh
hashtag dumb people town at Squad
Brothers on Twitter at danielvankirk on
Twitter still for now still there and
then we can uh tell you who sent because
sometimes people send the same story
like we'll get the same crazy story like
50 times right and we go back to the
first person gives us a timeline that's
the one good thing it gives you a good
show it's called dumb people excellent
science sometimes all right this story
is
textbook I mean quintessential dumb
people it's like a lost kid at a fair
it's just you know it's gonna happen
and his parents are divorced right
everyone just crying while holding a
corn dog that he didn't pay for a giant
turkey yelling grandma and she's dead
there is no Grandma right
Liz Hagerty thank you here's the
headline man torches cars after
dealership dealership sold him bad Jeep
so he's now taking it did you sell me a
back car I'm gonna take care of your
show you this is like he's like Sean
Connery in The Untouchables right they
ruined one of your Jeeps you ruined
three of them you ruin a Sebring like
yeah you ruined two Jeeps you put their
sister in the morning yes
that jeep does sound like a version of
Bad Lieutenant sure you know like the
Jeep is bad yes it's unpredictable bad
Jeep with Louis Gossett Jr red Jeep is
Nick Cage he's bad cheese
if there's Not a Bad Lieutenant Port of
call Long Beach with Snoop Dogg I mean I
will leave I'll walk off the set if dog
is can I just for a moment just talk
about how present he is in his life it's
yeah for as high as he is all the time
he is so present there is this little
thing on tick talk that is so funny or
maybe it's on Instagram called there I
ruined it there I ruined yeah I've seen
it where they take songs and mash them
up yes you know it and they try and mash
them with the worst possible things but
the funny thing is they're like you
didn't ruin it you actually made it
better well this smash-up of Snoop Dogg
and like a 1920s like no it was like uh
from the bear the bare necessities
what's that no it's oh Jungle Book they
did it to the Rhythm and beat here's
what I found he did it to the rhythm of
bare necessities from Jungle Book yes
Gin and Juice oh okay yeah yeah yeah I
can find and it's great because Snoop
then dude found it and then he clapped
with it don't worry about that just
starts mouthing it along to what they
did and in a very fun way so Port of
Call report of called Long Beach so I
would say Snoop Dogg not since like the
70s have we had someone and I don't
remember he gets all his credit for
being an amazing recording artist and
rapper sure but he's transcended to just
known American entity like a Paul Lind
like just like a just like as somebody
who's just these were famous in the 70s
and Carson would have them on just to
like talk and maybe they were doing they
were doing a show in the Poconos like we
met him twice and we hung with him twice
and he remembers one there you only
remember there is a magnetism to this
dude that is you're like even if you
didn't rap you are just the most
magnetic human being you are just a
person and the fact that you can rap and
the fact that you're really good at that
I mean he's just an amazing guy I don't
know how people do that in that I find I
I'm not somebody that I like I'm not an
introvert I like being in social
situations but I find that the it takes
a lot of energy that I then have to go
away and replenish and I don't know how
somebody at his level is able to do that
all the time being like so many
different points there you go okay here
we go a man is excused
of setting fire to vehicles at two
dealerships two only one soldier a Jeep
nope yeah this is this is bigger than
this is a GMC Jeep eagle-wide how many
times fish rots from the head that's
right you cut it all off how many times
has he looked at somebody at the bar and
said this is bigger than this bigger
than us this is bigger what you said
it's bigger than that that's what Jason
said this is bigger than this you're
like what is that you know what I mean
the suspect is charged with four counts
of arson after he was seen on video
around 1am on July 17th at the O'Daniel
used car lot in Fort Wayne Indiana Oh
Daniel oh Daniel oh Daniel Daniel it was
time it was time for the chickens to
return to the roost
that's not what it is okay so this guy's
not in the military
and he's gonna use phrases that sound
military or drunk right it was time for
the chickens
what could that mean chicken
it's supposed to be the chickens have
come home to Roots right yeah but I am
going to tell you I have never
understood what that means and I know
that Malcolm X said it one time I think
regarding to Kennedy's assassination do
I look it up and people got oh it's all
you wanted okay so if I'm if I may be so
bold I think it is a podcast within a
podcast called look it up with Jason
it's just Jason looking stuff up so if I
may be so old I think it is you put
stuff out into the universe good or bad
karma whatever it is and when the
chickens come home to roost that's when
the chickens come home to sit on the old
sailing is the CH the saying is chickens
have come home to roost is normally used
to mean that the bad things that someone
has done in the past have come back to
bite or haunt the individuals so maybe
this person is right I'm not saying that
they're not right but I think as
fundamentally as a phrase I would think
if my chickens are coming home to roost
I feel great yes thank God I think yeah
I think it is supposed to have a
positive they've come back they've come
back I stayed at my uh uh friend's house
one time we went up to Montecito and a
friend he like lives up there with his
family he was like well we're gonna be
gone for the weekend why don't you guys
stay here and we have chickens in the
backyard all you got today put
themselves away watch out because these
[__] will come they will come
home they will come home to roots and I
was like cool all positive
and the kids there's like this side gate
door sure kids left it open yeah
chickens get out no
apple juice the chicken no never seen
again no
here's the thing Lemonade's running
around in the front yard and I'm like
going through the bushes being like [__]
[__] [__] I know and we I called him and
I was like look man I'm so sorry apple
juice is gone apple juice is gone we
have no more apple juice he's like if
he's like you know the coyotes probably
will get them they will find their way
home if they are alive and one out of
the three found their way home yeah I
think it was like I think crackers
crackers awesome crackers yeah crackers
is a new chicken
crackers just stares at a blank TV
screen for hours but it was like it was
like his child's chicken that sounds
like I can't buy [__] killed the
chicken
got home the kid was like yeah that's
fine
the kid was like yeah whatever whatever
nothing's different the chicken's there
it will like cock-a-doodle-doo at Sunset
now yeah I know that that's not right
but it's just been through some stuff
thank God seen some things uh so the
suspects charged with foreign the quote
from the suspect is it was time for the
chickens to return to the roost okay
said the how old Fort Wayne Uh man how
old is the guy that would use that
phrase and get mad at a bad Jeep and go
set fire to multiple vehicles at two
dealerships he's been pushed that
he's gotta be I'm saying at 1am 1am he's
not gonna be in his 50s okay he's not
gonna be old enough okay to be out at
1am okay
I'm getting a look like oh because I'm
going in the 50s but you're going in the
future I'm gonna say mid to late 40s
because he's still he's the phrase
because he's been around long enough 47
47 okay 58 58 yeah
64. 64.
the guy who's pissed about his bad Jeep
and said the chickens have returned to
the roost is
79.
[Laughter]
he was waiting for Deborah to die she's
gone and there's nothing to stop his
anger how many times Tim has he said the
phrase I have had it up to here well he
probably says there yeah he's yeah
he said it four times that day not even
related this is bigger than this these
chickens are coming to the roots yes
with this I I'm not saying that people
should go out and burn you know I agree
none of us they're not even if you're
impressed that a 79 year old had the
wherewithal at 1am at 1am to do it and
all he got up to pee and just kept going
I feel like we have lost a sense of
proportional response yeah sure I feel
like we have done I'm not like I would
sort of like raise pacifist like I
understand these things but I'm also
like you know what
you [__] deserve to have don't give
this guy up don't give a 79 year old man
a bad Jeep unless you want and look
we're all thinking of o'daniel's car
dealership as it lives in our mind these
people might be asked they might be
terrorists right there might be a whole
group of people sometimes I mean they're
on Facebook who are like good yeah
retribution can seem intense but
sometimes people have gotten the
retribution they deserve what they
deserve you've done enough to deserve
this he's like I don't want to burn
these I don't want to burn these but
I've been pushed too far right if if you
just go around punching people that's
rude horrible if you punch a Nazi that's
it that's fine like it's fun and also
they earned it they should go well yeah
of course I signed up I got in it I live
the punching line I'm in that's the game
I'm in if I didn't want to play tackle
football I didn't want to get off the
field get off the field and change your
uniform while you're at it that's it
okay that's it the man told the Fort
Wayne Police Department that he started
the fires as revenge against the
dealership which he said yeah
which which he says sold him a Jeep why
do I feel like when the cops got to his
house he was already into the story they
weren't even out yet and then this
happened walking out to the line I'll
tell you what they did like no one's
asking finally you want to know you want
to know you're probably here because all
those Jeeps got burned right so he told
he told me this was revenge against the
dealership which he said sold him a Jeep
with a bad motor and quote refused to
make it right this is when he bought the
Jeep in what year in what year do you
think he bought this could be a
long-standing garage oh wow he's 79. and
what deer do you think he bought a Jeep
they sold him a bad motor they refused
to make it right and the chickens are
roosting in town they're coming into the
roostings yeah area this is a long play
like a really long play I don't know Tim
you want to go first Tigger or third you
can where do you want to guess
we can guess prepared to you if you want
to hear where we're going if you want
more time to think or you I want a
little bit more okay so then you'll go
in the middle of us go ahead Jay I I
think he bought this car in 2013. okay
wow 10 years ago it's a 10-year long
plan Tim what do you think
I'm gonna go sort of biblical with this
okay I'm gonna say that I think he
bought this Jeep in the like mid to late
90s in 1998 and has been like quarter of
25 years died yeah yeah yeah and doing
this is what I do now as she died she
said go get them go get go get him
with her last breath she said don't
leave me here he doesn't have a bucket
list he has a checklist a to-do list
we're gonna tear this thing down so I'm
I so was that 25 years 1998 25 years
I'm just I'm gonna go crazy because I I
wanted to go crazy last time I said 64.
I was in the right direction sure I
think he bought this damn Jeep in 79.
wow he's 79 and bought it in 79. okay 44
years ago and by the way and I'm sure it
had Dan I'm sure it had a great motor
back then and then like all cars that
are that old the motor does I see you're
blaming him yes
yes I'm spinning this one in all right
okay
this man a 79 year old man
bought this Jeep
in 1986. oh my God oh my God
you are wondering if you're closer Randy
I know you are seven years
I was not even that was where my heart
was going where's January yeah and then
he goes I'm going to get a Jeep so he
buys a Jeep
it's an 86 motor did he set them what in
what year did he set the Jeeps on fire
now this year now Long play I was right
to say this is from August
2022. if you if you bought a car and win
1989 86 years ago 36 years before this
happened you've got 37. if you got nine
years out of that car good for you you
did great unless unless unless when he
bought it it was bad yeah he wanted them
to fix it they said he said he took one
more drag and went all right okay we'll
see we're all right fine you don't want
to help me out there
they thought he forgot about it sometime
when you least expect it I'll be back
I'll be back I don't want to bring up
Mel Gibson sure because you ever see
that movie Payback yes where he like
puts the cigarettes in his mouth
backwards and rips off the filter and
throws it away and then he's like he's
always like burning somebody alive with
gasoline because I don't know I think
somebody gets killed I was just
picturing this guy like an old ass like
anti-semitic racist uh just like dumping
gasoline and just like ripping an
unfiltered cigarette and throwing it in
the little gas trail that he made the
video oh hell yeah shows the man opening
the fuel door of a 2019 Jeep Compass and
placing an ignited road flare inside the
fuel tube according to yourself up yeah
the man then drove off the lot in his
car while the jeep was engulfed in
flames the fire grew no [__] and ignited
vehicles on either side of the Jeep
including a 2013 GMC Acadia and a 20
2020 Jeep Cherokee kind of feels like
they're just trying to sell cars it
feels like somebody's and you know what
you can they are burning off the light
yeah hot and ready to go red hot deals
it's a move gang all three vehicles were
destroyed in the fire and worth more
than how much combined just for a quick
fun one we're talking used yeah you got
a 2013 GMC Acadia you got a you got a
Jeep a 2019 Jeep Compass and a 2020 Jeep
Cherokee I want to throw in used car
market was through the roof in August of
22. yeah yeah yeah yeah what would you
say
three cars range cars uh yeah one was
two years old one was three years old
and one was nine years old at the time
68 000 okay fifty two thousand sixty
seventy thousand
s
it's so good you were close to getting
both showcased after leaving the used
car lot the affidavit says the man drove
to a second oh Daniel dealership in Fort
Wayne there the man used a knife to cut
open the roof of a 2008 Pontiac Solstice
why base convertible model leave a
Pontiac
Pontiacs are just barely it's them and
the sun fires are just hanging out
through enough yeah damn we had a
Pontiac six thousand six thousand that
was our first one with the Bonneville I
had a Grand Am my first adult car was a
Pontiac Grand Am but think about it he
went to the first dealership and he's
like [__] these Jeeps I get that you got
a bad Jeep
it's an iPhone yes I'm selling for a
Pontiac Solstice
I don't hear collateral damage from the
weird thing about a Sebring that feels
like yeah
so he cuts open the cloth top right then
drops an ignited Road flare through the
slit in the roof onto the driver's seat
something works if something's worth go
with it yeah if it's not broken don't
fix it
his phrase if something is not broken
then don't try and go changing it or
fixing how many nights did he pour just
a glass of unchilled Canadian Club
looking at those two flares being like
someday someday someday I got all sat on
that rage seven decades decades so the
flare drops onto the driver's seat
catches fire uh created heat and smoke
damage to the car's interior the damage
to the convertible was greater than its
823 value yeah so in 2022 a 2008 Pontiac
convertible Solstice they're saying
twelve thousand eight hundred and twenty
somebody what is that oh Daniels yeah
yes somebody named O Daniels or Daniel
wrote this article look at how much
money I'm losing yeah I'm losing 69 000
or someone close to him so that he can
then claim the insurance off hey where
there's smoke there's a fire sale yeah
the man also told officers that he
placed Loctite super glue and other
accelerant in the door locks of cars on
and oh Daniel lot shortly after shortly
after purchasing his Jeep in 1986. so
wait so he already hit him he already
hit him why are you hitting him again
this is not a proportional response
thank you the first one is the problem
with your first one was though too
subtle yeah because they think that's
kids and it doesn't even make the news
right yeah and it's the there is certain
sorts of breakdown and you know liquid
and stuff you can get rid of it's gonna
take a long time but you can get rid of
glue he is filled with rage oh my God
filled with rage have you guys ever been
close to a burning car
uh just driving past yes we drove past
one and it was like semi coming out of
Vegas heat was Unreal 10 miles coming
out of Vegas semi fully engulfed no way
mine was also come it was on the way to
Vegas yeah I've had that one the heat of
it you can feel inside your car inside
your car it's pretty it's pretty wild
wild it's wild we used to do a huge
bonfire in my hometown of Rochelle
Illinois huge part of homecoming week it
hurt your teeth yeah you and you're not
that close to it at all
um all right here's the final thing on
this okay while watching the footage the
man identified himself that's me right
there
yeah he invited he identified himself to
police and said that he was upset he did
not get to watch the fires he set oh my
God after he saw the damage to the
convertible tell Cersei it was me
he told police quote that's all the
damage I did wow
I don't think he's done without Daniel
by the way he's loving this part of it
so he's going to go to jail then he's
going to go to jail yeah he's not going
to jail
they're gonna say they're gonna say
clearly if he can hold a grudge for 36
years he's going to go do it again he's
a danger and he had already gotten him
once right dude you got to get him all
right that's Story number one my friend
wow oh my God just way too old a long
Grudge
seven years he held that Grudge well
yeah well when he did it it was 36 86
until now so he's 79 Now 37 years
possibly yes 37 years earlier he was 42
years old yeah or right yeah 42 43. I
mean that's a guy who like really for
years Christmas after Christmas was like
I'm gonna take him get them I'm gonna
get them I just want to say the fact
that there are more stories your
listeners just what a joy
that you guys I mean like if you gave
him the one they would be like that's
pretty good the fact that you're like
you know what we got more two more two
more to go we're gonna tell you guys all
about uh Tim and Matt Walsh's uh podcast
which is coming back it's all exploring
people all that on the other side of the
break it's dumb people town with Tim
Simons we'll be right back
hey guys welcome back to the show uh as
we were mentioning before before we get
to talking about the podcast and uh the
Matt Walsh Tim Simon's uh reboot we'll
call it a reboot sure uh let's talk
about what we have going on Jay uh June
14th you got a big show June 14th we're
doing a show and I think we're going to
do it once you're doing your show now
that's our show at The Comedy Store in
the belly room it's called tag it it is
the most us show ever we also basically
get a twofer guys because you get a
great comic doing a great set and then
that same great comic interacting with
YouTube great Comics almost doing
another like group set of Comedy where
you pitch them great jokes uh yes so Tim
what happens is our friends do stand up
and Jay and I are off to the side in
real time writing pitches to their jokes
that we then go on stage afterwards and
say I love this bit I love where you're
going I thought you were going to go
this way have you ever tried doing this
or what about this we pitch them and if
they want them they can have them it's
like the what happens in green rooms
ever and back hallways of every Club
ever is comedians yeah so we're gonna do
it on stage so
comedians it seems like famously love to
be criticized yeah so this is a great uh
this is a great let me try and make it
constructive and not so preachy but
you're right I know comedians famously
are able to differentiate between
constructive criticism
into the mouth of a lion as far as that
goes that's June 14th at The Comedy
Store Dan did it last time and it was it
and we have a pardon on Cheryl is going
to be on this one Doug Benson's going to
be on this one Ian Edwards is going to
be on this one just good people and
nobody else someone else really good is
going to be on it uh Daniel let's talk
about uh what you have going go to
danielvankirk.com I got dates coming up
uh East Coast Midwest uh Southwest even
some stuff around here I think one of
those dates is going to end up being a
special slash album recording so
um all that'll be coming up so just keep
an eye over at Daniel Van Kirk on
Instagram or danielvankirk.com plus I
have my show every other week with Irene
two it's called best bet comedy you can
follow that show or myself I promote it
as well at Best Bet
comedyard too on Instagram and uh at uh
scholar Brothers as well and our patreon
is fantastic too for five months we do
all sorts of great to hear about you
losing luggage yeah it's good stuff I
had a great luggage story on there uh
Tim so let's talk about the podcast
where you guys go back and look at
second in command sorry guys I'm
smashing that patreon button after I
heard about the luggage story yeah it's
a good one these two traveling getting
mad at each other is the greatest thing
in the world worth just hearing Jay's
vitriol to me plus people send in their
own dumb stories like fans send in like
here's when I jumped into a cactus
garden
catching a frisbee I mean it's
unbelievable stories and then we find
some old crazy stories too it's really
super fun all right second in command
second in command Okay so second you
guys are back a little bit of a year
Hiatus you're here a little bit of a
Hiatus have a new home at uh all things
company very excited about it uh the
idea is that you know the the we're
trying to tell the we're trying to
remember how the show was built because
we had a really we had a strange process
that not a lot of television shows do it
was very not only collaborative but sort
of workshoppy it would
um our Mando who started the show would
talk about how it was like a studio you
could just keep putting stuff in and you
boil it down you keep put more stuff in
and you boil the right way to do it and
so we're trying to get you know
everybody that is a fan of the show is
familiar with the end product and I
think we're trying to give a sense of
not only how it got there and we're
trying to give a sense of how it got
there but also
you know it's been a long time since
these episodes now have aired and so we
are coming back with like some some
distance from it yeah it's just kind of
fun to to relive it I've done so mad
about this like the Genesis of your
character as well oh yeah and you
develop it in the evolution of your
characters
like you finding Jonah and then like
Jonah's place in that world is so you
know because you very much start out
like you pop in and out and then it's uh
there's also the the differentiate the
yo-yoing of status is for us with that
character is so
it was like I remember the first time I
saw him at a hardcore show and I was
like oh my God yes this makes sense cool
this guy would do this that one I
remember being like Oh like this is kind
of the scene that I was into when I
would have like been going to shows yeah
and by the time I shot that I was old
enough that at the end of the day I was
like oh my neck does not move I was I
did not warm up I mean like I truly was
the age where I was like oh I have to
lie down yeah this is and this is what
you're gonna get in the show is like
little stuff like that that people just
yeah great little tidbits and I bet it's
great like if it's a Sam Richardson or
Randall Park people you guys bring in
and talk about that process of someone
it's almost like double dutch they've
got to come in and hit this like pace
and hit this Rhythm and find it and I'm
sure not to speak disparaging but there
was probably some people that it was
very challenging for and then other
people it was such a litmus test to be
able to be like oh you're in like you're
in you're in you're in like definitely
Sam was one of those people I Dan back
at all was like my mom hit the ground
running oh this is Dan's made for that
like yes Rank and like nut cutting and
also I love so much in Veep of how
people get so high on an idea or a
motivation and then that just gets taken
out if I wanted them every time yeah and
I do also think that there is something
fun about like and I I'm I think this
might appeal to you guys specifically
like sort of like generalized comedy
nerds like we like trying to like parse
out just like something's funny in that
thing of you know when you're
criticizing your friends stand up yeah
you know you're trying to figure out
what why is it funny why did that work
where did that come from I want to ask
you one cool question before we go sure
I don't think you had worked with Julia
Louis-Dreyfus before this correct was it
people have just said and I've talked to
other people showed that they're like oh
you just got it you're like oh you're a
genius and your like ability to like
work off and play I mean she's so primed
with Seinfeld and all that other stuff
but it was like oh there's just you're
in it like we're just a team and you're
just she was I mean it's incredible I
mean like I think it's she's such a
legend yes
the work that she's done is incredible
and she's like so there was a certain
intimidation that I had going in of
course but I think that she is somebody
who is very uh she is a generous
collaborator and even though I did not
have the experience of really anybody
that was there I I was never made to
feel like it was I I was never made to
feel like it was a bad idea to
participate right she and Armando
created an environment where we were all
able to trust one another and find it
and so that's the best yeah
we come out every Tuesday I forget to
talk about things uh yeah it comes out
every Tuesday
um and it's been very fun well you know
you guys are super funny so I would just
listen to you guys talk about anything
for sure but then it happens to be this
show that's something that you know so
good all right second and come back in
the command subscribe to it I've got the
next story sent to you by once again Liz
Haggerty okay our friend lizard you
ready for this yeah here it is Plymouth
man this is the headline man riding an
inflatable Swan rescued for the third
time this week that is insane
one time rescue rescue me once shame on
you rescue me trying to shame I mean
what point do you just name on the
community let him go third time you
rescue me don't ever rescue me again
right I'm like this with people when you
walk in someone they're like don't let
the dogs
the third time your dog doesn't want to
live here that's right can I tell you a
story yeah
so one of my mom's friends from Lamaze
class perfect sorry
buttons she had she like their second
kid so like the the older the middle
their middle son was like my best uh one
of my best elementary school friends
because they met Lamaze class we were
friends as babies and all that he has a
younger sister and we all go to the
ocean one day
and this little this little kid is like
two years old keeps like walking into
the ocean oh my God and the mom is like
just get back here get back here and
after the fourth time she was like you
know maybe she belongs in there yeah
like maybe she can't figure it out
yeah he's true honey when you get in
that Riptide parallel paddle honey
paddle smoke will you guys grab her
she's going by your bodyboard yeah
strangers and strangers just grab her
all right so a man has been rescued for
the third time this week after entering
Plymouth sound on an inflatable Swan on
a swan can I ask one quick question sure
yes I mean are these like rent to boat
swans like an echo Parks
they're blow up inflatable this is a
popular thing like a basic [__] like me
wearing a mimosas all day big hat yeah
we have a inflatable Swan we have that
just like uh when you put in a pool you
put your kids on
the latest rescue took place at
approximately what time after uh Port
control Port control observe the man
floating uh out there I found like dead
hookers
I'm gonna guess 4 30 p.m 4 30 p.m what
do you think Jay uh 11 A.M are we
talking about the third time third time
foreign
I'm gonna say the Barn's open uh you
know he was out for sort of like a late
evening kind of like a late evening kind
of Sundown I'm gonna see like this is 6
45 okay it's 4 30 11 30 11 11 A.M 6 45
p.m get your answers in townies because
the last rescue took place at
approximately 3 30 p.m
you wanted to eat lunch the Plymouth
Harbor Master Richard Allen Dick Allen
said uh to Plymouth live earlier today
and although he was not present at the
rescue he was able to confirm that the
man had been pulled from the water I
wasn't there I wasn't there I was off my
men and women you guys need me to give a
quote dick we got it no there's my quote
and when they tell me that this jerk off
okay I'm gonna say one word in his quote
and it tells you completely his attitude
if you're an actor and you're like how
do I play this guy nope he was on the
water a minute ago but he's just been
recovered he's just been pulled in
apparently apparently apparently
apparently is everything that's how he
covers his own ass yeah
the time of the rescue the man had just
been off the western side of Plymouth
sound you're taking this thing out here
what is a sound does it sound like an
ocean yeah it's like a a channel a Long
Island Sound it's like where's Plymouth
oh we'll find out hold on it's Jay's
podcast
all right I believe he was over to I
believe he was over towards the
Mayflower Marina again I'm not there why
was this person giving the quote I'm the
boss God damn it I'll get out there and
say what happened even if I only know
Parts I believe he was over on towards
the West though Mayflower can we talk to
someone who is out there no I got it to
me all right well you don't seem to have
any answer sir I'm sorry foreign
who are we really what is in a
gentleman's heart
it comes as police issued a warning for
people to not risk their lives by taking
to see in inflatable beds or animals you
know what is believed to be the same man
in choppy Waters off the hoe hoe on
Thursday November 10th it later emerged
that the man had already been rescued in
Plymouth sound the previous day he wants
to float out to sea yeah let's go let
him go let him so yeah Cunningham told
Plymouth live how this woman how she and
PC Chantel one's ex-wife said to his
kids exactly had been driving along the
hoe hoe I guess that's what it is around
3 30 p.m when they were frantically
flagged down by a woman who was trying
to ring 101. maybe this is in England
maybe this is oh maybe all right she
told officers she'd seen a man on
inflatable swan in the sea who
apparently appeared to me in difficulty
again if this is the third time you're
rescuing this guy like your friend's mom
let him go into the ocean yeah I don't
care if the water is perfectly calm if
you are more than 15 yards from the
beach yep in the ocean on a swan you're
going through a hard time
you want you want to get yes you want to
guess I want to be a choppy ones having
a hard time and that has nothing to do
you're an emotional you have a secret
you don't want to reveal yes
that at that moment that's the best
you've been in a while
it's like going by work best in
catastrophe have uh I
okay so you know there's the right
across the street from the Grove yeah is
the the like the Los Angeles Holocaust
Museum yes yes and uh and they have uh
you know it's a beautifully so
beautifully designed building
um uh that sort of travertine kind of
look uh and the walkway is it beautiful
yeah but they have the
anti-uh skateboarding pegs on the
travertys yes and the thing is whenever
I see like a a sign that says something
like please don't go out into the open
Waters a lot of people have done it a
lot of people have done it and there is
that thing where I'm like I just imagine
the sign at this place being like I
can't believe we have to say this right
don't go on an inflatable Swan well no
please do not skateboard on the
Holocaust Museum don't skateboard the
Holocaust don't skateboard on the like
the train tracks going into uh please
don't skateboard on those chips please
do not need you to pop up ollie on that
why did I why did we have to make this
sign I know they just were not happy
someone someone incredulous the office
officers headed towards the low location
the woman mentioned behind the coffee
Shack I love that they give that detail
yeah
coffee Jack somebody in there is related
to the coffee shop and the cops are like
we should probably stop and get some
coffee Shack right we just got oat milk
shut up
to find a few yards out there was a man
on board an inflatable Swan bobbing
around in the water is what they said
she said a couple of people were
standing there watching and sure enough
there was a man face down in an
inflatable swamp yeah right exactly oh
man with a taste with a tiny little
paddle can you imagine if the paddle was
like really really really small it was a
hell of a windy day certainly not
suitable conditions at all we tried
shouting out to him but he seemed
oblivious he wasn't panicking at all PC
Wildman went through the bag leave them
leave them yeah the bag and found nearby
and got his neighbor and she began
shouting his name as loud as she could
get his attention she was bellowing look
at me and listen before saying she'd
throw him a tow line we keep in every
police car by some miracle this is how
Point Break should have ended he caught
it and we pulled him in when we got him
in so they did all this to get this dumb
ass in got him in thank you he goes
right back out again we tried to explain
the dangers of being on the water on
inflatable we're telling him we are
concerned about his safety that these
things were not meant for the sea at the
best of times let alone a windy day when
the tide was really high I told him
these things are meant for swimming
pools how many people have said I told
him he was just saying you ready this no
no no it's fine which is what every
drunk person says whenever you're trying
to get them to do anything we're leaving
the bar now no no no that's fine we need
to get in the car
I can't quit drinking whenever I want
nope it's fine get up we're going to bed
no no no it's fine the brain will do
that the brain will will and he means it
when he says no no no it's fine it's
fine you ready for what he did she's
gonna call me it seemed oblivious to the
strangers and then he did the most
eight-year-old thing that any adult man
nope tried to reason with him but he
deflated the Swan and ran off just ran
up the steps and was gone did he take
this one took a swan with him a deflate
they ruined his day the potential to
drift further and further out meant that
we even called uh the police Marine
launch just in case we're unable to
reach him with the tow line the officers
were left shocked at the man's behavior
but more shocks came when they uh
climbed back onto the steps of their
police vehicle only to encounter a
couple of paramedics who happen to be
having coffee at the Hogue Cafe again
there we go are they are you sure
they're not at the coffee crotch or
whatever it's called coffee shop they
now have ice mochas yeah
I need to say that out loud we got some
half calf options if it's later in the
day and all that's in here we are out of
we've got a lot of flavored seasonal
syrups
obviously Starbucks has a trademark on
some of them but if you want something
that's a lot like a frappuccino they got
options do they got peppermints pumpkin
flavor it's not pumpkin spice
you know it's the same thing we were
remarking about the strange incident and
they went What We rescued him a day
before he did exactly the same thing
yesterday the same man and probably the
same Swan on the water being bashed them
in the wall by the way so again how many
times you get lost out to sea we said
that in the end uh do you I mean and
this is that's the end of this story but
like he he's definitely going out there
again am I right he has not learning yes
yeah that's what he does but like what
also part of me hopes this is just some
sort of weird viral marketing for the
coffee Shack and they're like Gregory we
need you back out there again get out
there Starbucks is gonna kill or we've
mentioned I don't want to go out there
anymore just go look every time you're
out there we get three more public
servants who have to come out here and
get coffee while they wait for you we
tried to throw them we try to throw him
coffee Shack Punch Cards which you know
they're doing five for one yeah this is
a guy who gets talked to through
clenched teeth a lot yes yes put it down
get in the car deal with it yeah all
right there you go that's Story number
two down the book Jay can you give us a
little taste of what we're gonna see
inside I really cannot believe that your
listeners are getting yet another person
to get another one more insane you get
one more uh worst text ever from a
doctor love it okay okay we're into it
Tim Simons is with uh and he's got my
dog on his lap and I'm okay with that
that is what's going on this is the best
it's dumb people in regards to your dog
you're first in command second there you
go command there you go that's his
podcast with Matt Walsh you got to
subscribe check it out uh we'll be right
back to more dumb people town it's
bringing it home right after this
[Music]
boys I have to tell you about my
electric e-bike I'm so excited to be
here first of all I got one of these
which is why it's mine yes my family is
trying to steal it from me all do not
let them take it I have it up at the
cabin it has revolutionized my family
using the cabinet you go down to the
little General Store you hit up the
little Resort on the lake grab yourself
a little Sammy for the summer
that is number one so I what I have
always wanted to do more of when I'm at
my family's cabin is like go out more
and explore explore I go for a ride dude
I go for 10 15 20 miles it's just me in
the wind I'd go no headphones it's
literally like I can check out on this
thing yeah and ex like experience more
of getting away and it's all because of
of my electricity I love them I want to
say it before you say it if you are
hearing me talk about this get one yeah
it is like before we had smartphones
people
really like to talk about it it's like a
technological Revolution remember
everybody like if you had an uncle like
me and they're like I don't need one of
them smartphones and then you better get
like oh this how did I do without
changes how did I have a summer without
electric e-bike so again and you explain
this but you roam freely you can reach
up to 28 miles an hour and I know Dan's
pushed it on his uh with your humming
with the twist of a throttle and pedal
assist which I love because you're
you're still working you're still
getting exercise yeah but it's pushing
with you and it's helping people Dan and
you said you go back and forth from the
lake and whatnot you can add those cargo
baskets and bags huge Comfort upgrades
even passenger accessories uh to certain
e-bike models so they have they they
really make it easy for you to customize
and they cost less than the competition
you it's compatible so you can get it
into your car or SUV obviously your
truck or whatever let me say so ships
free and fully assembled how about that
that's the coolest part there isn't like
a like all right well hey I got
so we say get out explore your world
with an e-bike visit
electricebikes.com learn more and
explore the Epic models electric has to
offer that's electricebikes.com
l-e-c-t-r-i-c-e-bikes.com townies
whatever your Fitness level is or
whatever your goals are fitbod builds a
dynamic workout plan just for you and it
optimizes future workouts based on your
personal progress so what are your goals
that's you gotta ask the key yeah like I
know that I myself I want to lose weight
I want to I want to lose weight I want
to firm up I want to be doing something
every day I like to work out at home so
like I want it to be things that I can
easily do and I go through the fitbot
app which I have and it has like
designed to work out for me at home that
is like perfect even for me though like
when I'm on the road my thing is this
goes back to like playing sports in high
school yep I just want to show up tell
me what I have to do for the time I have
to do it I will follow
because I don't want to be negative I
don't want to have an opinion and they
literally you say like I want to do this
like Foods weight for me it's that as
well and then it will tell you this is
your workout today it'll give you a time
in between the sets which I really
really love so that there's no like oh
I've been on my phone for 10 minutes
before I started this Next Movement Like
that's right it sticks with you and
tells you what to do now it's so well
organized and it's kind of like and also
it's not yelling at you it's like it's
just it's just right there for you to do
but then because it's an app you can
keep track of your achievements
I get so into like you've set a new goal
I love that I don't know or you've done
it 12 days in a row yeah this is you're
actually being consistent with it kind
of keeps you honest yeah I think that
personalized workout plan designed for
your Fitness level and goals it just
they create that custom workout it is so
good your personal goals and experience
it gives you the Habit build the Habit
with what you have available maybe
you've got dumbbells maybe you got
kettlebells it helps you sort of with
all the stuff that you have you build
your Fitness Habits Stay consistent also
it's wonderful so wherever you are in
your fitness journey get the most out of
every workout with fitbod and townies
get 20 off your subscription at
fitbod.me
DPT that's
f-i-t-b-o-d dot m e slash d p t
[Music]
hey guys uh welcome back to the show I'm
gonna bring us home shall we let's bring
it into the Bad Doctor text yes okay
this is set in front what if it's just
Dad I think I left something in there
damn have you seen my keys yeah bad
things this is uh sent in by Jake hey
you're gonna get an email tomorrow don't
Sue yeah we're already suing ourselves
yeah we let's talk it out first before
we call anyone uh just hear my side of
it here it is my last patient was such a
dick oh sorry sorry wrong person
new phone who this uh here we go
surgeons so it's multiple doctors
sorry for texting patients they had
aggressive cancer instead of happy New
Year oh
oh my God this is Jay caroney oh my God
so they don't have cancer no this is
like when the nuclear thing went off in
Hawaii right yeah yeah they meant to say
happy new year but it came out you have
aggressive cancer kazoo yeah did they
send it on New Year's Eve or on New
Year's Day they may have uh askern
Medical Practice in the UK has
apologized after texting thousands of
patients oh my God to let them know that
they had quote aggressive lung cancer
cancer with metastases two days before
Christmas merry Christmas because it's
on the 10th day of Christmas my doctor
texted me there you go ask her in
medical practice is a surgery center in
Doncaster on December 23rd I'm just
crazy this is nuts it taxes patients
with an unusual request to fill out a
ds-1500 form it's okay I'm just going to
say this on the flip side of this and
we've told this story before right
so it's going to be a great well as far
as you know you actually may some of
them probably do but the stuff that goes
to your brain so when we were in New
York I'm sure we told the story on here
our friend Scott landsman did one of the
greatest pranks ever on our other friend
Eric Friedman with the lottery was like
up to 100 million dollars in New York
and we all bought tickets and we were
like they're about to read the lotto
numbers and our buddy who lived with us
Eric went into the bathroom and Scott
took these like I'll take down the
numbers he said if it go if it comes on
I'll take down the numbers so he took
down he wrote one of the numbers of his
like of his like eighth thing not the
top number of a thing and then just
turns off the TV before they read the
numbers and he goes uh they read them
let's go out and and I wrote it down and
then he's like Randy wrote like the
entire series but kind of Shifting
around a little bit right so he goes in
the bathroom and our friend Eric comes
out to just look at the numbers and
starts reading through his numbers and
he's like oh my God I want
and he starts losing his [__] and for a
brief second
a hundred million dollars my life was
going to be different forever and then
he's like Scott Scott and Scott can't
can't help but because he's cracking up
so much and he hears him laughing he's
like you son of a [__] but for that
reason so I don't know how long it is in
between texts here but these people like
my life I just want to say that who is
the person who played the pranks Scott
played it on Eric so Scott played it on
Eric yep Eric is well within his rights
to 39 years from now yeah 100 now
everything this guy that's everything
that Scott owns on it that is yeah that
is unforgivable that is it was he did
forgive him so cruel it was hilarious
all right so on the 23rd they sent out a
form that allows patients with terminal
can to claim benefits quickly so just
try to send a text they sent this form
you have something terminal this is how
you can claim you better get those so on
Christmas Eve instead of wrapping the
presents for your kids why don't you
fill out a bunch of paperwork also think
about getting a hold of these doctors
it's Christmas Eve diagnosed it was the
day before but aggressive lung cancer
with metastases the message said
according to the BBC askern has around
how many patients did they send that
message you said thousands so I'm gonna
give it at me 4 500.
I'm gonna say 6 700. wait where where in
the UK is this k-e-r-n
uh I feel like I've never that doesn't
sound like a neighborhood in London and
I kind of feel it doesn't feel like it's
a town that I've heard of so it's
probably going to be on the smaller so
I'm going to go lower okay I'm gonna go
I'm gonna go 1800 1800 all right they
have get your answers in eight thousand
people oh my God they sent that message
to 8 000 people oh my God the message
and I guess you at least you still have
the group
you know I mean you saved the group chat
so to speak so the ma the message was a
mistake no sure obviously except for the
person who actually does that who found
it out and the scent and the center
texted out an apology directly how long
Okay so this is after the initial 10
minutes I think 10 minutes
it takes it takes a half an hour to even
understand what's happening right I
agree so I think I'm going away but
you're gonna try to jump on that quickly
so I'm gonna go 55 minutes later 10
minutes I think two days wow well come
on Christmas yep someone's doing this on
Christmas and it's like a Christmas
miracle okay they wait till Christmas we
go Merry Christmas you actually don't
have cancer unless you think you
actually might in which case here's how
you can schedule an appointment what'd
you say how many men ten ten he's 15
days one of you is close Okay the answer
is about an hour so you might you were
right I mean he's right about an hour is
dead on according to the text the
surgery center meant to wish its
pacement patience well by dead on I mean
you're all going to be dead how does
that mean they're not even close we
meant to wish you well have a happy
holiday like wouldn't you eat a
fruitcake joking if you got the first
text you'd be like that person it's it's
they want to get out of the office it's
the holidays They're copying and pasting
they have two window is open one is
everybody your email the other one is
are texting the other one is someone you
have to text yeah who already knows this
information and needs this stuff and
they [__] flipped it send it to the
group we are asked as human beings to
multitask too much the modern world asks
us to do too many things at the same
time we're probably listening to this
while driving or doing eight things so I
say this all the thing out of time or
walking into the ocean yes riding a swam
into burning a Jeep on phone no I I say
this whenever I get on a plane and
forget my charger I'm like I'm being
asked to do too many things yes remember
when Sheryl Crow at the World Series
like several years ago was like playing
harmonica and playing guitar and she was
setting up her microphone I'm like can
someone please do this for her she's
doing too much somebody's got to do one
of those things one of those things get
a person out there to work on the I know
she's a solo artist but don't let her
help her please accept our sincerest
apologies for the previous text message
sent is that enough no not enough yes
well you wanted to get something out
right away the apology says this has
been sent in error our message to you
should have read we wish you a very
merry Christmas and a happy New Year our
message should have read you have
slightly aggressive no our message
should have read we're all gonna die at
some point yeah eventually but Happy New
Year no one lives forever Happy New Year
I don't think there is ever enough so I
think the best thing to do is just to
we're just all I can say is I'm very
sorry in 8 000 let's just be generous
50 of those people the like sorry
mistake are gonna go okay whatever and
then you've now you're then you have to
start willing to know who is going to
nag at you about this mistake yeah clear
as many off the table as you can right
away and then just start individually
yes we understand no you can't legally
sue us we didn't do anything really
wrong and you don't have cancer yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's crazy the
follow-up message on the surgery center
Facebook account on January 3rd blamed
both human error and computer related
issues while no data was breached we can
confirm that an admin staff error was
made for which we apologize immediately
upon becoming aware of we said we would
like to once again apologize sincerely
to all that's not enough I would have
thrown more in there like I hope this
moment of facing your own mortality
really makes you think about your New
Year's perspective so really you're
welcome yeah it's a new lease on life
you're welcome it's like a Fight Club I
know where you live now I have your ID
go do whatever you're supposed to go do
with your life send out another message
saying goodbye it's been a pleasure
serving you as your as your medical
facility we can help you find
everybody's going we can refer to you to
other people because we're closing shop
but you know what maybe that's like a
you go to some other place that's like
if you've been on a plane that crashes
and you survived you're never gonna have
to worry about a plane crash again you
go to the place that sent out the [__]
up text message now they're they're
never gonna make that mistake that's
right yeah that's right that's right
it's buying you buy low you buy yes you
buy love uh it was an internal patient
supportive task among admin staff to act
upon and not related to you as a patient
anyway this was an isolated computer
related error for which we are extremely
regretful steps are being taken to
prevent a recurrent reoccurrence I think
you got to say more than that yeah the
apologies do not lessen the shock ask
her in his patience felt for that hour
on December 23rd between the first and
second message I just quote I just had a
mole removed and was awaiting result
from a biopsy that's the worst case my
smear test came back abnormal so yes I
was very worried one woman told the BBC
yeah she's allowed so yeah like you
could feel the yeah I was worried but
also you know how your bank will never
initiate any sort of uh conversation or
correspondence via email or a letter
right if you get an email right if no no
medical profession will ever text you
hey you have cancer yeah it's nobody
that's it they will try to call you
every day for a month and then start
calling you twice a day that's true bad
news LOL
yeah they should not have put an emoji a
poop emoji after it but I feel like
that's whatever whatever no but there is
the the like in a marriage and in a
relationship we all know that like you
kind of want to we need to talk is the
worst thing that's the worst thing you
can hear so someone having bad news or
wantings usually they want to tell it
face to face so I think you're right but
the flip side of that is when you have
the upper hand over someone who's really
screwed up in your relationship that's a
good position oh yeah because you can
show up at that office or you can call
the doctor and be like yeah I need to
talk to you about something and no I
won't wait yeah you show up to the
office for your checkup and you're like
tell him to get his ass in here I don't
want to sit on that thing yeah a lot of
people are starting to demand a lot of
they're going to be dicks for a while
and they got to sit in it they gotta
take it you earned it you just gotta eat
that you gotta eat that [__] you gotta
eat that [__] you gotta eat it you made
it Merry Christmas Christmas morning
felt pretty great to all those people
use your wallet and then find it uh
you're learning real leaning real hard
into the year welcome Dad is all about
you're welcome I'm that silver line you
a favor
we made you appreciate your life you
lost your wallet and then you found it
that money's worth more appreciate your
life this is
yeah there you go It's a Wonderful Life
and it's a wonderful podcast uh second
in command that is the podcast right
here on all things comedy yeah check it
out subscribe if you love
veeps you want to hear them talking
about life in Baltimore oh hell yeah oh
hell yeah you know I have such a soft
spot for Baltimore sure it's it's I mean
like it's rough living in like you know
it's a hard like when you don't live
there and you're just kind of going in
for a couple months it can be like oh my
God I'm just the most depressed I've
ever been but I really do love that City
it's a great City it's very much like St
Louis where we grew up but just shifted
onto the East Coast yeah uh go watch the
movie Diner and that'll get you on the
ball in the Balmer mood or go listen to
a Ryan sickler podcast dude you are so
great I'm so happy you were here with us
thank you for coming back
any time and uh oh [__] we gotta get
back to work guys
town
[Music]